that's a quote by Seiran Kirk søren
kierkegaard who said that life can only
be understood backwards but it must be
lived forwards and what I want to ask
you is what thing in your life at age 20
was perplexing and and then makes sense
now through the lens of time experience
wisdom you know I always say science
means knowledge it doesn't mean wisdom
so now that you've accumulated wisdom
what thing would you tell your 20 year
old self that seemed impossible and then
venturing into the impossible gave you
clarity and into the reality of this
aspect of your nature well it's it's
going to be very it's going to sound
very specific but it actually governs
all of our lives I was astounded by the
brutality indifference fool T of my
elders and I did not understand the
extent to which the entire world changed
in the early 1970s in a structural
fashion there is no up sight I I
wouldn't put it exactly 1971 sometimes
in 1971 and 1973 the world changed
character in a way that can be easily
seen I think it's called WTF happened in
1971 why an introduction somebody else's
version I did not understand that my
entire life
as an adult would be lived in a bubble
dominated by generations that cannot
come to grips with the fact that the
world changed structurally and punishing
those of us who came after them forcing
us to live in a simulation of the world
before 1971 through 73 that we are
eventually going to have to pay for and
for example when I started working for
Peter Thiel was a guy who has many of my
opposite characteristics you'd never
think we'd get along but he's slightly
younger than me by a year or two and I
always thought I had a problem with
authority and I thought I had a problem
working for other people
and more or less we've gotten on great
for seven years and the reason in part
is is that I only worked for people
considerably older than I was or under
and I realize that this is just a very
serious dividing line and that this is
bubble which began in Italy in the fall
of 1945 when World War two ended and
ended I think on February 19th of this
year 2020 when the market figured out
that Corona was going to be a big deal
been a 75 year interruption of reality
and in particular the power nap was
between 1945 and 1970 through 73 and the
rest of the time after the interregnum
73 on has been this bubble of complete
unreality I think most people that I
know don't realize that they've grown up
in the Truman Show it's a universal
Truman Show and it's cracking this is
the end of it and so you know in an
interesting example inside of the
university system is look at the career
of Norman steam rod on the math
genealogy project a guy whose he advised
his last advisee 1972 right when this
thing changed and all of these students
go on to become a professor it's
impossible for everybody to train
professors to become professors and they
have 20 students but they're 22 higher
and higher powers and you see the
explosion and so in essence we have been
growing up in a simulation of a world we
have never seen and the
intergenerational stuff is so far thrown
off that we are actually considering
having an election between a 74 year old
man and a 77 year old man when
previously you know one before Trump
Ronald Reagan was the oldest president
ever to take the oath and inauguration
was 69 this is not believable and if we
do not
realize that we are going to have to pay
the bills of our grandparents and
parents and we have no resources to do
it we are spinning out of control it is
time to recognize as much as we love
these people they have led us into a
very dangerous place far away from
reality we found out that we don't
manufacture our own masks you can't get
tests we don't have reagent we are
sitting ducks there is no government
effective there is no ability to convene
smart people there's no place that we
can we can have a Manhattan Project for
anything because we can't have smart
people asking questions because
everyone's too busy looting so I think
that this concept of Babylon that we
live in comes from a change in growth
regime that happened between let's say
1971 through 73 and just like the period
between 1952 and 54 where you have DNA
and the hydrogen bomb everything changes
sometimes over a tiny period of years so
if I if I ask myself when I was growing
up why are these old people so horrible
I would have understood that what
happened was that they've been locked
into a Ponzi scheme which is structural
and they weren't courageous enough to
stop and that it wasn't coming out of
personal cruelty it was coming out of
the fact that they just couldn't imagine
that they should live in any different
circumstances than they did so I'll
point out that that site is what WTF
happened in 1971 and I know that one of
the things that happened is very
important to me because that's the year
I was born
so it's not listed on the chart but it
was has some importance to me well also
the standard model more or less God had
put in place and I don't that's right
and some date that as you know sort of
controversially speaking is the end of
of the of the high growth period now I
mean what you're saying is in direct
opposition to a guest I had on recently
Peter Diamandis who kind of views you
know the future is getting rosier all
the time along with his friend Ray
Kurzweil and the so-called popularizer
of the singularity hypothesis that were
going into this realm of abundance and
and you've heard this in the
he speaks in the material world you've
heard this from Steven Pinker and even
Michael Shermer and in terms of you know
the better angels of our nature and and
rationality now and etc and I wonder you
know how you react to those you know
hypotheses that basically are you know
conjecturing something completely
opposite that seems like recently very
simple yeah if you if you don't have a
potential energy term you don't get
conservation of energy inside of a
physical system you don't have a
potential horror term
I guarantee but everything is getting
better as mister as dr. Pinker says but
the problem is the singularity already
happened it was predicted by Derek the
soul of Christ at Yale and around 1959
it came true in about 1971 through 73 it
wasn't the singularity in the diamond
Diamandis perks while are talking about
and Pinker can be explained by making
sure that you neglect the fact that the
potential horror has his conversion of
kinetic horror so yes it appears there
is a weird free lunch but if you'll
think about the blast radius of a
hydrogen device superimposed on your
favorite metropolitan area you will find
that in fact there is a price to be paid
for this piece in this prosperity you've
talked about the cell and the atom and
these two different nuclei problem yeah
and you know the problem is is that
Pinker will appear to be right until the
AH is impressed upon him in isn't my
friend Nassim Taleb
as fond of saying the farmer is awfully
good to the turkey right up through the
end of November